We'll now adjourn for a second and begin our
budget workshop on the Housing Department. Thank you.
This time I'd like to welcome Director Keith Bottom and Ms.
Tamika Jones to provide the Houston Housing
Department budget presentation. Good afternoon.
Good afternoon.
Joining me today is my assistant director and Chief
Financial Officer, Ms. Tamika Jones. If we
go through the next slide,
we are a department of acronyms. So here's a list of all
the acronyms that we use. So we just wanted to provide
you with that. If you go to the next slide, please.
For the General Fund, we are probably the smallest budget you
will see. At this budget hearing. We are projected
to get $411,604 representing
FTEs of 0.3. That 0.3 is represented
by personnel. And you'll see
the FY 23 budget of 135,493,
which is the three which is part of
my salary as well as employee exit costs,
as benefit termination pay and workers
compensation. And then the other side of that chart,
you'll see the other services and charges which represent
$276,111
which covers janitorial, rent and other miscellaneous
chargebacks. Next slide.
Let me get a little closer.
All right. Is that better? All right. Thank you.
If you go to that slide, you'll see all of department programming.
You'll see single family home repair and
reconstruction. Single family new construction,
home buyer assistance and home buyer choice.
Multifamily programs, public facilities and
public services. Next slide.
Our general fund revenue overview. You'll see on
General Fund from FY 21, we were just under
half million. And now in FY 23,
we're at 411 six four from
the previous year. That's a reduction of $6,114,
a 1.4% reduction.
Next slide, expenditures by
category. You will see on the expenditures
and we can go by those. And in purpose of
saving time, we'll just look at FY 23,
the proposed It's 135 493
for personnel, 160 for office rent,
99,084 for restricted accounts
and then other services and charges just over 17,000
for a total again of 411,604.
The next slide is our personnel versus non
personnel. And you will see here that personnel
relates to 33%. Non personnel is 67%
of those dollars. Next slide.
Our general fund budget expenditures. Again,
in order to save a little time,
you can see that previous year we were 417,718
compared to the current proposed of 411
604. Again a 1.46%
reduction. Next slide.
And the next one on this one
is our organization chart. So you can see the
current organization. To the right, you will see
all of the people who report directly to me. And as
of today, we can add an additional person. Kanesha London
is now my new assistant Director in charge
of Compliance. But that chart to
the left is the chart that represents individual
departments who receive funding and represent employees
in those other departments which total to 88
employees that are funded through us,
along with our 266 employees for
a total of 354 employees.
Next chart. And that chart just gives you some of the
demographics. Let you know that the
department is 39% male, 61% female,
and then the ethnic breakdown of the department.
Next slide our
FY 2023 new awards. This is a breakdown of
the anticipated funding that we will be receiving.
And you can see CDBG. Turs HOPWA
home Emergency shelter. Grant Our State
Homeless Housing Fund and general fund
add up to just over $62 million.
And then you can see the chart. To the right is a breakdown of 40%.
Of that funding is CDBG 18% Hopper,
17% home, 19% Turs,
3% ESG, and then
the Texas Housing bond money is 2%.
And then the general fund dollar is
zero point 66%.
And that is our presentation. Thank you, Director.
And people may be sitting here saying, why do we even do a budget for
a department that has balance or revenue
stream, expense stream of $411,000?
It's because of that last slide. It's because of the flow through.
It's because of all the money that goes from agencies,
whether it's the federal government Glo into your department and
then out. It gives us the opportunity to ask questions of you,
because last time we saw you both together, it wasn't a pretty picture we were
looking at. So I guess my initial question is how
is that going on the Glo side? Because we still are hearing from
residents that even though this is a budget workshop,
411,000 isn't a lot. But at
the same time, I'd like to just get a quick status update on how
things are going, how can we help your department move
things forward and what do we need to do?
So the gist of it is,
the last time we were in front of this committee, that was just
after September 21, when all things changed in our
department. Since then and at that point when we met,
we were having some significant challenges with
the Glo. Some of those challenges have not totally gone
away, but we have a more workable relationship with the Glo
now. We've made some significant progress.
Many of the programs that they put on hold are
now starting to be released and we're moving forward.
Our single family program that the Glo
took back, the only part that the department
kept was the pieces that were still in the pipeline. That program
is now winding down and we anticipate that program will be
completely wound down by mid to late summer.
So we are making some significant improvements.
The multifamily program, which has always
been one of the carrots in
our portfolio, has done extremely well.
We have also had some challenges with the Glo in accepting and
moving forward. We provided them with loads of information
so we can start moving those programs forward.
So overall, we have made some significant improvements.
There are some things some of our programs have been slowed simply
because of primarily the pandemic. Some of those
changes are due to supply
chain issues, a lack of inventory.
We have a significant home down payment,
first time Home Buyers Assistance Program.
But the inventory is starting to dry up and it's very difficult
to provide that housing when individuals can't find it.
But we are making some significant improvements since
the last time we've been here. Thank you. Council Member Abby Cayman.
Thank you. And Director, I really want to congratulate you.
You have always been with the department
for your extended tenure, leading with such dignity,
consistency, and diligence. So thank you
and to your entire staff. I also really want to commend you all.
We've been hearing around the Horseshoe how
important especially, I want to say, with single family homes
in that program and the rebuilding, the flexibility that we have afforded homeowners
that other I will say state agencies
have not afforded that flexibility in
terms of rebuilds and things like that. And I think that's a really big success
story that we are seeing on the ground here. We just did a
groundbreaking halfway kind
of checkbox on some multifamily
housing in the district that we're seeing in real time
all of the progress that we're making. I'm a little concerned,
just as we're seeing and Mayor Pro TEM talked about this,
the housing market, the affordability of housing
right now. And with you saying about that inventory
drying up in terms of single family home availability,
a little concerned about that. And we'll submit some questions through
the portal, but I appreciate you raising that. My one question is,
given the constraints that we have as a city financially,
and I'm asking every department this, what are the needs that are
currently not being addressed that you foresee can be a challenge for
the city either near term or down the road?
Well, I think the biggest need is perhaps
asking for additional or more money coming from general fund.
All of the dollars that we typically use or have available are
going to be tied to the federal government,
except for the tourist money. But the tourist money is already predetermined
what we're going to do with that in most cases. But we
have a tremendous amount of need in
the city when it comes to individuals who need their home repaired.
And because of some of the restrictions that
come with the federal dollar, it becomes very
difficult to assist individuals who are not homeowners.
I am a little bit challenged with trying to assist
just renters in general, because we don't want to
enhance a property that they don't control. And we enhance
that property, then the property owner comes back and either
increases their rent or even
worst case scenario, puts them out in order to get more
value for that property. So it becomes very challenging to
assist renters, but we also find ourselves
finding it being very challenging assisting
individuals who can't meet all of the needs, even though they may
be the homeowner, but they don't have everything in place to prove that they're
the homeowner. So they've been in the home for a number of years,
may have been awarded the home through someone's passing,
but they didn't do all of the things necessary to
put the property in their name. So they still technically cannot
prove that they are the homeowner. So it becomes very challenging when you're
trying to use federal dollars to assist those individuals.
That's why it would be better if we had additional general fund dollars
that would be more flexible.
Thank you. We have about ten public
speakers that signed up, so we'll go through the list real quick.
The first we have is Mr. Christopher Rivera, who is
joining us virtually. Christopher star six to unmute.
Hello? Can you hear me? Yes, we can hear you. Great.
Thank you. Housing programs becoming increasingly
important due to the rising costs of living. This year, the Housing and
Community Development Department will only receive 0.1% of the city's
general budget. Local reports indicate rent
has gone up 22% in Houston, and just last week there were 783
Evictions filed. We are facing a housing crisis, and the city
continues to cut funding that keeps our community safe. In the last
ten years, the housing budget has decreased by 82%.
The city of Houston is only one federal budget cut away from
a housing program disaster, an impact that will be felt
by low income families who will lose everything. My questions
are, how will the Housing and Community Development Department work to
secure a self sufficient budget, one that moves away from
reliance on federal funds? Why has
the funding for the Housing Department decreased by 83% in the last ten years?
And why does this department rely so heavily on federal grants?
Thank you. I didn't hear the last question. Why are
we dependent upon federal grants? Was his last comment.
The city of Houston is an entitlement city. We get the
majority of our funding does come from the federal government.
Majority of that funding is coming from HUD.
We get funding through a number of programs,
through HUD CDBG, which is our normal
funding source. We also have home. We also have ESG
programming. That has always been the way the
department has been set up and the way the city has been set up to
receive funding from HUD. The dollar
amount that we receive is based on a formula that has been
preset. That formula was designed
in the late 60s, early 70s.
That number has been the same, and we have not been
able to get her to deviate from
the current formula. Even though we are growing in size
and have grown in size since the original formula
was created, it has not adjusted anywhere in the country.
And there are some cities who are not as large as us receive much
more funding than we do. But it was based on the formula and amount of
need that those cities had at that time.
We've inquired, we've asked, but the formula
has not yet been changed.
I don't have a really good answer about
how to get
an increase in funding from the city. We can ask for additional
general fund dollar, but that is a budget issue. That is
always going to be a budget issue.
Sorry, go ahead. When it comes to
assisting individuals that were facing eviction,
we are currently dealing with some funding that we did have that
is dealing with individuals who are in the midst of being evicted
at the present time. Great.
Thank you. In person,
Mr. Jason oliver.
Hi director bynum thank you for your presentation.
First, I noticed, and there was a recent county report
that basically showed that we have almost none of the necessary
supply for what's described as extremely low income,
zero to 30% median household income housing.
Is the department set up to even shift that
severe need at all?
Yeah, that's my first question.
I missed the beginning of your question where you said you
saw the statistics that came that said what?
So there is a severe shortage in the
supply for extremely low income, like zero to 30%
median household income housing,
and we're just in no way equipped to provide to
meet that need and that demand in the near future.
Well, we are trying to meet the demand in a
number of ways. It's very difficult in single family
ownership. We do try to do a better job in
trying to meet it in the rental market. So we are trying
to provide that in a number of opportunities by
preventing or asking all of our developers to look
at an array of income
structures so we can provide rental
units for all of the streams of income in
the city. It is very difficult because there is a large pool
in that group versus the number of units that we can put
on the market. Okay. And then this
is, I guess, a question for council, because you've come here saying
that you need the time has expired, which council members are supportive
of an amendment to allocate more general funds for the housing department
so that you can address the issues that you talked about before.
Thank you. Thank you. Baba Blandy.
Hi, good afternoon. I'll start by reiterating Jason's questions and
use my time to answer that. And I also want to follow up on Christopher's
question. And a lot of times I've come up
here and asked, like, what could you do with more? But I'm actually curious.
It was very shocking to me that in ten years,
your budget has dropped by 83%. You went from almost
2.5. The next year was like, 1.4, and then
it dropped to like, 677. And then even in the past seven years,
it's been reduced by 38%. And I'm just curious, how has this
impacted you all's ability to provide for the city of Houston?
I know, like, what can we do to increase the housing department resources to meet
the needs. I know you've mentioned increasing the general fund budget, so I'm going to
circle that back to Jason's question. What council members are open
to a budget amendment to give our city what we need? Because you
don't need to be here 2 seconds before you see how many people are unhoused.
And we know how insane the housing market is
here.
So, Director, isn't it true that
we have additional dollars that your department utilizes for
housing that's outside of just the general budget,
federal dollars, state dollars, grant dollars that are just
not encompassed in your presentation today?
That is correct. We would also have access to the tourist
dollars. And the tourist dollars are
designed to help with the development of affordable
housing. Can we go back to slide twelve?
Sorry, Council Member Pollard, is it okay if I just track real quick
to what you asked? Well, let me get his response
to this. I just want to clarify where all
of the resources that
your department is utilizing for housing needs within the
city of Houston, and on page twelve, you have a breakdown here
of different funding sources. Can you elaborate a little bit
more on that? So you'll see on the breakdown on
the housing sources, sure. Everyone realizes that the majority
of our dollars come from CDBG funding. That's our largest pot of
the pie, $25 million. And then you see Turs
12 million, hopper is 10 million. And we can
go on and on. What you are presenting
today is just the general fund. That's all we're presenting today is
a general fund piece of the budget. And your follow up?
Well, Councilman Pollard, I understand those funding revenues,
but what concerns me is that ten years ago, their general fund budget
was almost $2.5 million. And it paid as our city
grows and as our housing prices skyrocket,
that our city budget is being reduced so
drastically. But the question I would have,
and we can get this from the department and then get it back out
to the public, is how much money were we getting from
outside sources as well to supplement? If we
were at 2.5 million before, what were we getting in CDBG?
What were we getting in Turs? Dollars. Because that plays a role also
in, I think, how we allocate dollars from the general fund.
So if you can work on that, Director,
to show maybe ten years ago what
was coming in from a funding standpoint from outside the city as
compared to now, sure, we can get that information to you. Now,
I can tell you, I've been in the department for 30 years. When I first
got to the permanent CDBG, funding at that time for the
city was over $60 million.
But as they began to get additional
municipalities join the group, as the
need grew around the country, then the dollars,
they're just limited dollars. So the dollars start coming down council
Member Alcorn thank you, Chair. In other cities,
do they operate in the same way with most of the money
coming into their departments being from the federal sources?
Our local dollars are of course the Tours dollars are coming into it.
Or do other cities within Texas spend more
general fund money?
They tend to give their department a little bit more general fund dollars.
We've seen cities outside of Texas who really
do give a larger contribution from
their general fund to the Housing department.
Philadelphia stands out, los Angeles
and a few others, I believe chicago, they tend to
dedicate more general fund dollar to the department. Thank you.
Council Member Thomas staff.
Hi.
So Council Member Thomas just wanted to express that we
have an annual action plan that's outlined
to support homelessness and all federal allocations.
And in response to your question, the reduction of general fund money is
because positions and programs were attached to federal money to leave the
general fund. So that's her
note. Thank you. Okay, I appreciate
you all's time. Sakunda Joseph.
Hello, I'm Sakonda Joseph. Like wakanda.
But thank you for your presentation.
I had other questions, but I just think it's an opportunity to
make a statement is that I do want the council members here to
know, which I know that you do that right now, the city
of Houston is number one in evictions, number two in
folks not having access to affordable housing. Many people
who came, a few people who had came here earlier today were people who missed
work, left early. Some people couldn't come because of work
because they are in trouble. I get calls on my own phone
about the evictions, and since February,
I've been so stressed just as a human being
here, living in this city that care about the people that
are in this city, until I'm trying to figure out what it
is that we can do to do better. So I don't want you all to
look over what was said. If there's opportunity to
if the budget has decreased over ten years,
for what this? For what we can do,
right? We understand. The federal stuff aside, I really hope
that folks that are elected by the people take the time
out, because I'm taking my time out to think about what
we can do to increase the budget to make sure that a lot
of our citizens are housed and have a safe
place to say thank you. Thank you.
Carrie Colleague I
just want to thank you for your presentation and I'm
just going to read my question. According to the Kinder Institute,
evictions cost Harris County over 240,000,000 a
year prior to the economic impacts of COVID-19.
Harris county and the city of Houston are not direct
comparisons, but there is a lot of overlap.
And I want to know what does your department propose as solutions
to address Houston's eviction crisis
similar to what Sakanda said, we have a lot of people that are being
evicted. And I know that you stated that you
need more funds. So my ask
is that City council would propose
redistributing some of those funds to specifically
housing so that we can address that situation.
And then my second question would be okay,
finish your second question really quick. It's just about repairs
and just funding for single home repairs
and rebuild. We have a lot of people that, even after
Harvey, are still struggling to fix
their homes. And although there are some programs
I recently called as soon as a month ago, and my
aunt specifically, they were told they had no funds in the
city to help rebuild her home.
Let me ask you your first question. In terms of the
dollars that came into the city to assist
individuals who were going through the eviction process.
We were able to serve between it was a joint venture between us
and the county. We were able to provide assistance to
over 70,000 families and put
out nearly $400 million
in one year. We were able to do that,
but the need was so much greater. Correct. And we
just did not have any more dollars. We put out
all the dollars that we had and the dollars that came
in remaining that we got from
areas that did not spend those dollars. We put that for individuals
who were in eviction as we speak.
So we eliminated rental assistance and
went directly to individuals who were in the
process of going through eviction as we speak. So that's
where those dollars are, but we just don't have any additional
now we've asked for additional funding. That funding just has
not arrived. Thank you. And her second question,
the second part of your question. When it comes to repair,
again, the dollars are limited. We can only do what
we can. It is a very difficult
product in dealing with home repair.
As I mentioned earlier, one of the major issues with dealing
with home repair are the individuals who cannot prove that they are the
owner. We have our hands tied
with being able to provide assistance to individuals who are renting.
So it is a very challenging process
in getting those done. The difference between what we did versus
what the Glo did was the Glo takes
the list and if you're up next, if you're ready to go,
then you get service. But if you're not ready
to go, if you don't have title and you don't
have all your ducks lined up in a row
ready to receive assistance, then they move on. What the
City of Houston approach is, we try not
to leave anyone behind. So we have volunteer
lawyers. We try to put everyone
into a process that allows them to get a complete
service. Not just are you ready to be
served? If you don't comply today, then you just
miss out. We're really trying to do everything we can
to not leave anyone behind that becomes very challenging
and it does become very time consuming.
And we're doing that with limited dollars. Thank you.
Julia ardua.
Thank you, sir, for your presentation. I also want to say
I stand in solidarity with all five people that spoke before
me. I'd like to ask which council members
are supportive of an amendment during
this cycle to allocate more general funds to
housing? I think that's really
important then to you, sir. I'd like to ask,
has the department examined eviction rights to council
programs as seen in other cities? If so, what would be
the cost to provide that legal representation to histonians
facing eviction? Could you repeat
that question? Yes, sir. I'll take my mask
up. Has the department examined eviction rights
to council programs as seen in other cities?
If so, what would be the cost to
provide that legal representation to Houstonians facing
eviction? We have not looked at what other cities
are doing, but we are providing legal services to individuals
now. Okay. And is there a cost to
those citizens? There is no cost to those citizens. We're footing
that cost. Okay. Thank you, sir.
Broderick Butler.
Director, thank you very much for your presentation. Again,
I apologize that I'm not going to speak to you. I'm going to speak through
you again. We're in a situation of calling a thing
a thing. The city of Houston,
and I won't say that it's in bad faith,
but I will call it disingenuous that outwardly
the city promotes housing as a priority,
as something to champion. But when you look at the
real where the rubber meets the road,
math is math. So I don't know what to tell you
other than that. So I
find it very disheartening that the
citizens of this city and those that are moving here and
those that live here and those that have come and told you what
the reality is.
I'm at a loss for words. And again, I don't
use the word bad faith or lack of good faith.
I genuinely use the word disingenuous.
You put your money where your mouth is. Your money is what your
priorities are. And I think that
this is just a bad deal. So that's all
I got to say about that.
Well, just one comment.
We are very understanding and we
sympathize about all of the issues. And we do understand
it would be great if we could help each and every individual
that needs assistance. There's a lot of people in this city
that need assistance. We just don't have the resources
to do it. Even if we got an abundance
amount of money from general fund, it still would
not be enough to have
a significant impact on all the individuals in this city.
And we are trying to do the best we can by leveraging
the dollars that we have in order to have the greatest impact. Well.
Thank you, Director. I think I speak for all of us when we say that
we understand that you all are doing the best that you can with the resources
that you have. The city of Houston has priorities all across
the board, from solid waste to public safety to housing to
parks to libraries to airports to you name it. This is a city
with over 2 million people with a limited budget.
If you have $5 billion and you take from one department,
you have to give to another. And so we're trying to find ways in which
to allocate dollars in a fair and equitable manner, but also
trying to make sure that we reach the necessary needs of
all Houstonians. There's those that may feel like
we should put more money in housing and take more money away from a
different department, and then you have those
who say that we need more money in a different department to take
away from another department. So you're always going to have to have a balance.
And that's why you elect us to try to listen to your concerns,
which we do. And we thank all of you all for coming forward to present
those, but it's still a balance that we have to fit. And I
think your department does an excellent job of trying to do
the best you can with the dollars that you have. And I
want you all to know that directly from us as well.
There are no additional public speakers. This includes our
housing department workshop. We will now adjourn the housing department budget
workshop.